hey gang let's talk about that middle
class famous tour baby
getting bigger and better and it just
keeps her rolling on it's a live
stand-up comedy show plus we played a
little LRG with the crowd as I always
say great way to introduce new people to
the show so grab the squad and come out
and see us yeah guys in October we're
going to be in Nashville and then we're
headed up there to Indy then November
we're hitting Atlanta two shows added
there then we're headed to Charlotte we
got Philly Two Sold Out shows there I
apologize you snooze you lose then
December we're hitting Providence and
Boston those are currently sold out but
we're adding new shows stay tuned
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find out the group to be classy
or to just a big old piece of trash
trash trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at Antilles basement she's got
a big job interview tomorrow okay
Russian oligarch she's going out for
she said they're dropping like flies
over there oh you got me my co-host is
coming at you from across the table this
is a family episode he is the CEO of Ru
garbage and he is my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love him I don't
care who knows it give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan hey there gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
T-Bone from the rafters here we go
closing in 100 000 over there let's get
those up get the YouTubes up get some
[ __ ] comments over there on iTunes
what yeah okay show them how it's done
all right and then also uh uh charts a
little bit
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there you get bonus episodes
guys if you sign up now you get like two
years you get like 85 episodes of ayg
and 85 episodes of [ __ ] of uh what's
the other thing we do hard feelings plus
a lot of money made plus a lot of fun
videos yeah we got the crib videos we
got the limo drive we got the camping we
got the AC roulette we got the shore
video we have all that kind of [ __ ] down
there check it out and more coming down
the pike and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer X short in
there the magic man makes us all look
good works the ones and twos crosses the
t's dots the eyes starting to run the
show a little bit too on the road and I
gotta tell you I like it give it up for
T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen everybody
what up dudes yeah I got my hard hat My
Clipboard out there straightening a lot
of people out on the roads out there
surveying the job site yeah line all I
gotta do is order the mozzarella sticks
T-Bones got everything covered
I like it
um
a couple of things two tree things I
wanted to throw this at you you're not
gonna like it so don't get caught up in
the fatness of it okay
um I didn't indulge but I tried them and
I just want to say deep fried underwear
literally the definition of indulging
I had a couple to treat
so hers which might be a local brand
it's a region I think it is a regional
or it's at least
from our area it might be like a
national thing but it is so this Philly
brand called hers h-e-r-r make hers
yours yes has a kettle cooked chip are
you a fan of the kettle cooked chip I
like a nice Kettle cook that's really
what we that should just be the regular
chip yeah it's ruined a regular Jet and
that's a ruffle I need some kind of
texture over here here's the thing
kettle cooked Ruffles no kettle cooked
lattice cut they're like they're like uh
waffle fries yeah but they're real
I tell you if we landed on Pluto
tomorrow I'd be like ah this yup makes
all make sense better bring a bag of
chips
it's a long ride out there daddy Toby
it's the ultimate chip I'm sure other
Regional Distributors and manufacturers
make this lattice cut kettle cooked
chips do yourself a favor Duke dear
country of favor I'm not I'm not trying
to poke holes in your the whole
leadership here but how is it as a
Dipper dude it seems like it wouldn't
have the the strength to withstand a
french onion dip buddy it's got holes in
it buddy you could put a pool on this
thing I'm telling you right now it'll
hold it'll hold
you can you can do the earthquake test
on it this thing's solid you like them
because they're aerodynamic so you get
them in your face faster I'm telling you
dude there are no wind resistance that's
what it's like a tennis racket that's
really what it's like it's like a tight
tennis but kettle cooked
they should all be doing kettle cooked
sports equipment that's where you're at
now that's the level of fatness you
reached let me get a three softballs
deep fried but why aren't Pringles
kettle cooked I don't know but you don't
they don't need to be kettle cooked they
but they could
um you don't need to go to graduate
school but you're going to get a better
job with better pay if you do it sure uh
speaking of uh trash typically we start
off with something trashy he just came
up with stuff you eat uh
they're really good dude I was at uh uh
I was down in Philly and uh I was uh
coming home and I wanted to get myself a
nice sizzly while I was down there which
is the Wawa breakfast sandwich before I
blew out of town yeah
um they're not good they're [ __ ] they're
like they're not
they're fine but I just you grew up with
them it's like uh you know it's like a
little taste of home they're okay I
would disagree on the I I'm saying I
like them but they're not like if
somebody from out of state trying to do
they're like that's never had one
they're like this is a thing like it's
more
I don't think it's like I mean it's a
pre-made microwaved sandwich that's
sitting under a heat lamp it's not gonna
be when you put it like that you know
what I mean it's not like the [ __ ]
friendly crime we're talking glad you're
not working for the marketing department
or whatever it's not even fresh made
it's been sitting there eight hours
which makes it even better sometimes
yeah it does well whatever
but the the Wawas in the city are a
little dicey there's a lot of like I
don't trust I want to go I want a nice
clean Suburban Wawa go out to the burbs
so I'm headed home I'm coming through
Jersey I see big Super Wawa with the gas
station a whole nine yards I pull in
there dude this thing looked like
downtown Beirut it was [ __ ] crazy in
there dude there it just made me sad
dude there was a girl going through
going standing in front of the sizzlies
there was three left and she gets up
there she's opening the boxes what look
and inspecting the sandwiches before she
takes that's crazy then she took two and
I was like I'm [ __ ] I'm not touching
those things that's crazy crazy I would
have reported her so it was Heron
another girl and they gonna do their
Gathering [ __ ] are these dirt ball
chicks like like real dirt bag chicks
okay like dirty sweat dirty uh pajama
pants on
all Larger than Life very like they're
and they're were they wearing big puffy
DC Shoes No but very in that world
their knees were touching and the legs
are going out you know that you know
that look real real messy yeah it's kind
of like the knees were backwards or
something you know
it's a bad look cause you're not a
grasshopper clean your clean your acne
illegally can't kill her because she's
afraid
you're lucky we're in Jersey right now
and I respect the law the the dirty it
gets worsted so I and every corner so I
go there now I'm mad I'm like hungover
and I just want my sizzly now I can't
get sizzlies skip he's upset also we're
living in a society here This Woman's
finger in the goddamn bagel I mean
that's yeah that's crazy crazy crazy the
fabric of society is falling apart so
then they're buying all that [ __ ] that
I've never bought that like it's it's
all like new age canned drinks that are
like all different colors I think like
those cow tails and stuff
and I thought they were really like cows
I didn't know what they were dude I was
like I'm not talking in this thing
whatever that is get 80 here um
so they're buying all like it's like
that like [ __ ] like the Mountain Dew
cans and the monster can they each have
like seven drinks and they're blocking
me from getting my Wawa at least hey
which is a local Fan Fair you know and
it's all like just like everywhere I
turn they're just in my way and just so
I'm like these [ __ ] broads so I get a
I get a shorty I get a sandwich over
there and I go outside I I eat my
sandwich in my car and I go all right
boom
dude I'm driving out of the I'm leaving
the [ __ ] parking lot these two broads
are eating under a tree next to the
dumpster with like eighty dollars worth
of Wawa Food I'm like where the [ __ ] am
I it was a tough look dude the dirty
pajama bottoms in public is that's a
real bit I mean I think that's a real
dirt bike that's a very dirt bag Philly
thing too the dirty pajamas and Pub
stains on the shirt before you leave out
the house it pairs well with a nice pink
slipper that's now black yeah well you
know what we really started to go
downhill
um and Old Navy really has a lot to do
with this the fleece pullover
really sank the ship yeah you know what
I mean everybody that flooded talk about
flood in the block and also those things
but hoodies too hoodies
when hoodies got popular I would I
wait what do you mean when hoodies got
popular what do you mean please like
regular hoodies in general I've done I
mean they've been popular for hundreds
of years hundreds of years well you know
what I mean hundreds of years
yeah they've always been a hoodie has
always been popular I I feel in the 90s
they got real big they've been kicking
since 1930. a hoodie yeah I think you're
looking at the wrong one
yeah
here on the wrong website dude
that's no bueno
not a hoodie like we know it today yeah
the earliest clothing style was first
produced by champion in the 1930s was
banging back then
shout out to the Champs
that's crazy damn
why why isn't that like why isn't that
should be their motto like we're the
first hoodie yeah everybody else is
doing what we're doing yeah cool as [ __ ]
since the 30s that's pretty sweet
the hoodie all the way back uh but I'm
just saying Isaac are you talking about
the zip up too either way they either is
that a hoodie yeah because remember that
was the comedian's uniform for a little
while we were we were right in line with
that well it's also they were like nine
bucks at h m yeah well I can't think I
got mine an old old and easies yeah part
of the problem you know uh not fleece
though never I never wore fleece then
maybe this is just my perspective but as
a kid we didn't have hoodies you had
dorky crew neck
that's what I'm saying so hoodies got
bigger later
okay like more popular more well because
due to Hoodie they were more expensive
and it was like you had a crew neck
that's what you wore you wore a Russell
crew neck yeah the hoodie's weren't they
had those they had the it was a
different kind of fabric on the side
remember it would like stretch out oh
god
um tough look I'm a fat kid yeah
so we're talking about Nowhere to Run
they got more popular and then the
second they got more popular people stop
realize you didn't have to wash them
every time a crew neck you had to wash
every day you couldn't a crew neck
didn't really have what's this got to do
with the fleece epidemic because now
every fleece once people started getting
those fleeces they never watched sure
that's so you look what it's [ __ ]
corny and two it's dirty when you leave
out the house already it's got the
stains it's got a little whatever and
people are like think it's a jacket it's
not it's an article of clothing you
gotta watch these goddamn things yeah
that's what I was getting yeah
yeah hoodies are the uh fleece man it
really all went South when was the last
time you got your winter coat cleaned
what does that mean
I don't even I don't know how else to
phrases together words that'll make you
understand that what's your winter coat
that blue one that you have yeah
um I don't think I have a winter coat
I know you don't have a winner yeah I
don't want to come can we change that I
had the Whistler the J Whistler but that
was like that was like two x's ago yeah
but I never wish we could find the
footage of the old podcast we did he
ordered a code off Amazon called Jay
Whitley if you can pull it up a Whistler
a good dude he looked like George
Costanza in the Gore-Tex it was like
half Tire it was it was something it was
something else it said Michelin on the
back wow that was good good coat dude it
was huge that was when we had rough
winners you loved it you thought you
were the coolest and it fit for about a
weekend in that tight quick
got tight quick I remember after dinner
one time in Boston that was kind of it
yeah I got it it looks like uh every
other winter coat yeah
I'm not as durable though yeah
it was not the stitching's a little loud
less than me and also yours was like a
big coat for a big guy it was a it was a
it was a statement piece Mammoth you
knew when that thing was on the Block
yeah I think my I think I got like a 3XL
for it was like 40 or something I put it
on it was like 32 pounds it was so heavy
dude it was like mostly plastic it was
[ __ ] it was the heaviest thing I've
ever seen in my life it definitely
wasn't goose down
probably pigeon or something like that I
don't even think it was animal dude five
pigeons in every goat
s they didn't even pluck up yeah they
just threw him in there yeah bad news oh
you stink bad news oh sorry I don't know
I want to ask you one more okay no
please ask me one I was gonna transition
into the fam I was gonna ask you what
are you gonna ask um I can't really get
into the details of why I'm asking you
this oh God but I was curious have you
ever slept with a chair up against the
door
you strike me as a person that might
have done that
uh like the chair propped against the
door so nobody can get in I've
definitely said booby traps in places
I've slept to hear if someone I've
definitely done the glass by the door
recently what yeah in your home now
uh-huh
didn't I tell you the door was open I
told I told that story I think only an
old hard feelings or something I
I don't know if I had been drinking or
something and you woke up and the door
was open the door was open
open or unlocked like open not like wide
open but like not clicked locked and I
was like [ __ ] that but it was like three
in the morning so I set up a system of
bottles in case anybody came in it would
wake me up now I got hansy had a crush
of six packs to get the bottle but yeah
I wouldn't uh yeah I'm crazy okay Toby
uh never the door uh I have a window
I'll do as well what are you putting on
the window bottles okay I live in a
recycling center
I've definitely slept with a big knife
next to me a couple two three times sure
no I just yeah I mean I do that now yeah
what do you mean I just did that when we
were in the mountains come through my
Catskills I'll stick you yeah
boy it'll be our little secret too yeah
[ __ ] you lay them down
I know right where the arteries are yeah
but I apologize Gang This is a family
episode
huh why do you apologize for that
sidebar of crazy
okay that was good yeah yeah because you
can really wedge it up against the door
of course it works works really good
yeah I mean it's it's based on working
yeah I couldn't I can couldn't get in at
all pretty good what
were you at my apartment on Tuesday
night
Gang This is a family episode as you
know when you sign up for the old
patreon there could get a question right
on the air it's the best way to do it we
got a little bit of a backlog but we
promise we're gonna get to him KJ
doesn't lie and you could take that to
the bank AJ lies
not about this but I do lie
um this one's uh I wasn't even at a Wawa
today this one's from Mike from nothing
I really thought I caught you in a lie
the other day but then I was like you
don't you don't really lie I don't
because the anxiety I used a lot not lie
but like I mean you lie in a wild way
about things that don't matter I'm lying
right now I love I'll lie to you know
it's what's self-preservation you lie if
when you're jammed up or whatever but
the anxiety of lying and keeping track
I'm 36 years old at this point I'm
[ __ ]
well I am what I am you're getting me as
is I don't need to lie to impress
anybody I'll give you an example of my
lying I had those chips today on the way
up and I also had a sizzling
is that supposed to be shocking I know
I'm just letting you know okay
and I hate the whole bag
sure was it like a party bag like a
picnic you mean for the 40 more one of
those Johns no no was that all this is
fat core territory but was that all you
had what else was purchased at the Wawa
um the weekend there was a lot going on
no no just today just today yeah you're
like I stopped at Wawa what you didn't
just buy also who buys potato chips and
a Brit and a bacon egg and cheese
sandwich it was no the sizzlies are like
two for five it was noon it was
afternoon okay it was brunch basically
Dirtbag brunch a two dollar two dollar
pre-made bacon egg and cheese sandwich
and a pack of chips I got a Fiji bottle
of water uh-huh I got a bacon egg and
cheese sizzly
the chips the chips a sausage egg and
cheese sizzly because they're two
they're two for four or something like
that they're really moving the
merchandise you had two I I had two
yesterday I can't lie and uh those
hangovers get you and it's gonna sound
crazy no it's not it is for sure not
gonna sound crazy dude but they have egg
rolls at Wawa now
and they're pretty awesome I'm telling
you right now they're pretty pretty good
ah and that was it I had some gum too
and that's it I brushed my teeth I had a
coffee
I don't know I was just telling you what
I did oh all right so that was the
purchase the purchase at Wawa yes I
would just steal
a couple of countdowns
wait when did you brush your teeth and
where I brushed my teeth in my mom's uh
kitchen sink if you have to know that's
a bad look dude there was a year right
that was getting screamed at that time
would brush my teeth at the kitchen sink
when I was sleeping on my boy's floor
[ __ ] dude spitting over a [ __ ]
bottom spaghetti it's a bad look dude I
gotta take everything out of this sink
no not I mean if you're doing it once
but if that's how you're living
you know what I mean you got you got
bigger fish to fry than the dirty dishes
all right a [ __ ] hemmed up nine
different ways cause you're brushing
your teeth in this in the kitchen sink
you're late for work
for sure
you're hemmed up tight I wish that was
just honestly how I lived my clothes
were in the breakfast nook because they
weren't using it remember that little
room I had off the kitchen oh yeah
shout out to my [ __ ] homies from day
one started at the bottom huh
um but I was gonna say you don't really
lie yeah because I've done these for
days I thought I was I thought I I
thought there's no way I can prove it
I'll admit I I admit it I thought you
had lied to Luke and I that you had gone
to the gym an hour earlier than we did
no that day I went okay I think I ran
two miles okay that was alive it was a
mile and a half
I'm good baby
welcome to the club man yeah buy some
more go ahead I do all the time
T-Bone I love you buddy
I was gonna do the same joke to you damn
it we're hacked what do you want
we're well fed gang support for today's
episode is brought to you by true
classic true classic which I would like
to call the greatest t-shirt company
that's all I wear you're finding you
you're finally getting on my board I'll
be honest with you they sent us a couple
I had them in here for a couple of days
all right I wasn't sure if they would
fit me I took them home I took one out I
put it on I don't think I'm ever wearing
any other t-shirts ever again I'm
telling you guys I know I seen you out
there at the meet and greets we got a
lot of bigger fellas feel great they
feel good they're cutting the shoulders
right they cut around the the they hide
the spare tire a little bit it makes you
look like a like a retired linebacker
yeah you feel all yoked up jacked up
yeah they're tight in the sleeves to
their grave here's the turkey it's a top
quality Comfort fitting t-shirt it's the
only one that I'm gonna wear moving
forward and telling you right now yes
guys uh they're giving uh are you
garbage listeners the hook up baby go to
trueclassic.com with code garbage uh
men's tees are designed to look good on
skinny models and that ain't us baby toe
couple fat hard asses cooking around
here a couple of wide lose oh yeah
um so here it is uh it's time you learn
to dress like a gentleman upgrade your
wardrobe with true classic get 25 off 25
off these people are crazy holy [ __ ] off
trueclassic.com
one more time get 25 off trueclassic.com
with code garbage at 25 off and free
shipping over a hundred dollars with the
code garbage at trueclassic.com get
yourself looking like a doctor with true
classic listen
cut let's get to the turkey all right
guys it's a fan map yeah so the big man
said when you sign up for the patreon
we'll answer your questions on here
um this one's Mike from South Philly
ever own a pogo stick
I didn't have one there was one floating
around
I think my neighbors had it it was an
old what was it old metal it was [ __ ]
old as [ __ ]
and I was too young to has any that that
might as well been learning [ __ ]
Mandarin to me and let me tell you
something you could be looking at
seriously bodily injury a pinch a
testicle something that those things are
dangerous yeah those things need
constant WD-40 to run to run clean
didn't like them hated the pogo stick
however
I'm older than you boys 46 year old man
sure child of the 80s
let me tell you what hit
like a tidal wave when I was banging
third fourth fifth grade the scooter no
the Pogo ball the [ __ ] is the Pogo ball
there you go
the Pogo ball oh yeah the basketball
with the little with the rim around it
yeah it looks like Saturn yes it does I
never got that because yeah they were
all old and broken by the time I saw
them yeah they were like left over from
my cousins or something yeah you were
watching Degrassi or whatever the [ __ ]
you kidding how old what I don't know I
was only [ __ ] three years ago ah
Drake was in it yeah
three years ago no I was exaggerated I
was in college I think when that came
out really I think so yeah shout out to
high school maybe I don't know Pogo ball
you got it I do this thing [ __ ]
stinks no I'm telling you man they were
they were you would you would have
really dug it they were they were really
cool man cool colors and dude it was
just one of those things that everybody
had to add and for some reason we were
allowed to bring them to school there
was kids hopping around like [ __ ]
kangaroos through school then they
clamped down on it pretty hard well it
was big uh early 90s my sister had one
was the skip it yeah skip it so I
remember I remember that yeah I remember
the kids having them
high school at the time you're going
down
yeah there was something else that you
guys had too along these lines pop it
but no that's a game right yeah which I
would assume would give you a horrible
panic attack Bop It Bop it it's like
counts down twist it dang it
oh get the [ __ ] out of here with that
thing that looks like a Klingon ray gun
or something like that it's a baby toy I
thought that thing sucked you know we
played [ __ ] Simon whatever it was
called yeah
that used to give me anxiety everything
gives you I smashed a couple of those in
my day yeah I thought it was talking to
me one night shut up you [ __ ] British
bastard
he wasn't British Simon did he talk I
don't think that thing talked was it was
it called Simon says yeah it was a Simon
Says type game yeah the colors yeah
actually I thought that was alien
technology my buddy had uh these two
things that uh these two scooters left
over from the 80s that had like the
small bike not the razor ah dude yes and
it was like a skateboard it was like a
skateboard it was like a and they do big
they had like BMX handlebars on it okay
with the original scooters those he had
two of them and they were [ __ ] sweet
Metal Frames I completely top off curves
you could do [ __ ] every I remember
asking my mom like I want like can I get
one of these and all the [ __ ]
scooters we could find were like the
razors
that was that was a decade after but
yeah they were wacky [ __ ] but uh were
like toys this was like a vehicle this
was like a mode of transportation they
were [ __ ] little mini mag wheels with
the plan with them yeah I'll get you one
but we can only lease it yeah you can
only have it on every other weekend
you're gonna have to go eight blocks a
year if you go over it's 25 cents a
block I did tell you my stuff by the way
I'm cooking on the miles on big boy I'm
almost at 3 000. I picked it up in July
you only get 10 a year
they really bend you over 25 cents a
mile if you go over
here gives a [ __ ] do that math I think
I'm gonna live for three more years good
luck suckers good luck trying to pry me
out of this goddamn car jokes on you
Dirtbag
um I told you my stepdad built me a bike
with a sidecar on it
right I had to have
I didn't tell you that I vaguely maybe
remember something yeah a side so there
were these things just always empty
there no no dude we would [ __ ] if you
have a sidecar you have nobody to send
it because you got no friends I'm
sitting there waiting for someone to
drive it especially
I got a helmet on with a little scarf
yeah you can't do that on a bike
It's gotta be in a motorcycle
I'm 12 years old there's nothing cooler
than [ __ ] that I think you have to be
a Nazi to drive those too that's the
Nazis Rose getting [ __ ] up in those
Indiana Jones took out about 20 of those
things
ah they'd flip over
it was [ __ ] sweet dude I'm telling
you because my buddy came from
California and he had one but he wrote
it the whole way huh if you Google uh
they're called uh Rob Dyrdek tried to
like re-sell them like try to like they
were big in California in the 80s I was
called like the guy there was like teams
of competitions I learned all of this
after when I saw like he did it in like
sidecar magazine five or something yes I
called her sidecar quarterly
this is crazy right did you find it yeah
you like you can't really sit you kind
of got to stand I guess on that one yeah
so but the one my the one my buddy had
he got in like a bet like somebody owed
him 200 bucks and the guy's like here
you can have this so he showed up from
California with this like [ __ ]
sidecar tank and I was like yo that's
[ __ ] sweet and you hook it up to your
bicycle I'm not hooked it was welded it
was proper okay connected so I went to
what the bike looked like his bike it
was all just it was just kind of like a
random BMX bike okay with like a [ __ ]
like coming off the side like to weld it
to the back so my stepdad's like a
hardcore [ __ ] mechanic like race car
builder [ __ ] guy so he was like I was
like Brad I was like you gotta [ __ ]
see this thing like it's crazy and he's
like I can do that and I guess like he
saw it as like a challenge so he's like
yeah I remember you tell me [ __ ]
amazing sweet I was oh yeah who'd you
zip around there there was a whole group
I mean when you're like 12 everybody's
riding out on [ __ ] bikes in The Burbs
huh you're in the woods you find all
bike jumps from the 80s were you jump
around on that no yeah that was that was
like my Sunday cruising car probably
take that out for a drive who would you
take for a ride in it I mean we would
[ __ ] you know we would just like
drive it into the [ __ ] down like wild
you just do wild [ __ ] with it it was
like jackass was [ __ ] banging at the
time you were just yeah Pat flip
everybody Vinnie with the skinny I like
it it was a good time man I just
imagined you with a little teddy bear in
the sidecar like come on Mr mittens it's
time to get red I would like we're
running away it had carpet in it we were
on our way to start a restaurant in
Seattle
laughs
that was sweet slept two was nice
a mini fridge
pretty good
um all right whoa please I was gonna say
Pogo balls
that's where it was at shit's corny that
wasn't it was cool you would have dug it
if you were my age you would have dug it
I'm telling you for sure not would have
not done
I'm taking [ __ ] from a guy in a sidecar
hey you just sleeping on a basketball
going in in school like that's real
[ __ ] cool yeah it was cool we'd all
hop around a sidecar are you insane I'm
also not saying it was cool you said it
was cool multiple times it is unique
that thing is [ __ ] stupid dude you're
hopping around who wants to hop on this
is unique
I wasn't in high school you idiot I was
11 or something
[ __ ] dork all right Pogo balled up
until next time you're jumping to get
your diploma
Henry Foley by the skin of his balls
man
it's got to be pretty good
did you ever do any of that [ __ ] you
guys do any hijinks when you got your
diplomas no I hated that yeah it was
like class Clowny stuff that you know
I had never was uh I flexed on our
principal when I took mine though what's
up [ __ ]
no you didn't
and that was three sizzlies
shout out to the Wawa egg roll though
you're crazy also never mind we'll we'll
do a Wawa hour another time
um this one's from KJ the ass man having
a lion head or a full lion statue at the
entrance of your driveway hmm there are
there is a couple in my area not even
nice houses like just like It's gotta be
nice
yeah these were these were just like
random there's like a random like split
level house do they have like the stone
work at the end of the driveway though
like a little maybe a little bit but
it's like not that looks nicer than the
house it's tacky to me I don't know it's
real Russian mobster [ __ ] yeah a little
bit you know that in the columns if you
have columns at your front door but the
house ain't tight
anything like
to me that [ __ ] is like was all done
late it's like supposed to be done like
marble like that's what it was so it's
like this is just like a bad
representation of that to me yeah it's
like wearing a fake Rolex or whatever
I wouldn't mind but then somebody was
like
it would suck if you got [ __ ] robbed
or mugged for a fake Rolex I go yeah
that kind of stinks too why it could be
great no please don't take it it's that
forty thousand dollar watch yeah give me
a [ __ ] and then they run off in like
eight bucks yeah [ __ ] pistol whipped
or something not necessarily if you
gotta cough it up but if you don't have
a stop trying to be a [ __ ] hero hold
on hold on you're not getting the point
the thing is if I don't have any Rolex
I'm not going to get mugged if I'm
walking around with a fake Rolex people
go oh I'm gonna mug that guy for his
Rolex
so let's I'm probably not gonna get
mugged with that I mean you're probably
not gonna get bugged with it but it was
more of it would suck to get mugged
[ __ ] gun pulled on you
give me your roller yeah that's what
they all say
give me your sidecar too
you're right on the street in your
Sidecar
all right okay okay yeah lose the Lions
yeah yeah unless it's like half luck
yeah I don't know it's so gaudy that's
like so new money like
unless it's like a [ __ ] crazy Mansion
or something I get that yeah or a villa
or something you know what sweet is a
lion with the thing in its mouth as a
knocker oh I'll give you that yeah
that's all right that's tight we don't
have no knockers
red doorbell not too shabby that's
pretty good
um let's see here uh this one's from
Drew first time long time 10 investor
here which the homies you're not calling
themselves investor I like it I like it
gotta have a board meeting pretty soon
as your garbage do you rearrange the
pepperoni on a frozen pizza so it's more
evenly spread out not at all pro move
pro move I do it to the point of autism
I'm like I I make sure it's like [ __ ]
got to my OCD gets involved I run the
lines of art if I'm gonna cut here I'm
going to cut especially on a collie P if
you do the pepperoni you really gotta
Oregon and when you were a kid you
didn't think about that you're like ah
[ __ ] but now if I do it and there's like
a bunch of cheese in the bot in the back
I'll just spread it around a little bit
I don't do that because it uh it depends
I don't like that the fine cheese
that's like real that tends to like
break down and come to like a powder
sure nah okay I need to shred bro all
right that's just how I roll that's okay
but yeah classy move right there
redistributing
I'm also a fan of reorganizing the
burger like let's say you get something
from McDonald's and it comes and it's
like half slit off or whatever
take a minute stack it up the way you
like it sure get everything proper
before you dig into it no
um all right this one's for Matt ten
dollar long time shareholder anybody in
your family ever do Zumba
what zumba zumba would be like the
modern Thai Thai bow or whatever Zumba
was like uh I remember the girls in high
school or college
we're all doing so we're doing Zoom
Botanical it's like a dance maybe like a
hip-hop dance Tebow might be able to
tighten this up for me like a hip-hop
dance aerobics class go you go do Zoo
huh going to a zumba class it's a
fitness program that involves cardio and
Latin inspired dance
oh no I didn't let my girlfriend do that
[ __ ] what are you talking about
definitely [ __ ] that guy I think it's
girls some cool Cuban dude showing her
how to showing her moves why my fat ass
is sitting at home eating my [ __ ]
eating your Kettle cooking chips eating
your speed chips
yeah get out of here with Dad
no bueno
Zumba spin class was big I still don't
understand what that is spin no I said
Zumba but then I said he said zumba's
ping glass was big back in my day spin
class was big yeah I mean I think that's
still quite
very very popular that's a dance no spin
is on a bike see that don't make no
sense why bikes Wheels spin Ah that's
[ __ ] stupid that's why they're
calling everybody's Sidecar
so you're in the side guard some jack
dudes [ __ ] battle it
let's go Timmy
do you know my friend who lives in
California
he moved here and had one of these we're
best friends
okay
that was always hit or miss when a new
kid showed up in the neighborhood sure
that could really work out I was never
big on the new kid I Really Ever I
wasn't mean or anything I just go like I
was a new kid okay
bastard what's that mean you're not
coming over to my house that's what it
means yeah please Evan that's the whole
that's the whole reason I'm avoiding you
go over to your unpacked house no thanks
well you're over the kid that had to
show the new kid around the school
uh no I don't know if we had that here's
my locker
these are my snacks don't touch them
you ever had to do that I don't think we
had very many new new kids to be honest
with you
I don't remember that's a tough that's a
tough thing for a kid to do I'll tell
you that like show up in the middle of
the Year oh that was Tyler from a
Catholic School to a uh Public School
fourth grade
brutal everybody knew each other since
they were [ __ ] babies we thought I
was a cop but can I come rolling in
but I had a show I had a show
um
a kid around in I think six or in
seventh grade became one of my best
friends shout out to Chuck Stewart or
Charlie there you go showing around the
whole place
get you out of class you get to walk
around a little bit I could imagine you
really giving like that you know this is
I kind of run [ __ ] around I got laid
over there I got laid over there given
the [ __ ] H Foley lion tour
and see that teacher Miss scheibel had
banged her a couple weeks ago
in reality you're going through other
kids lunches
I was prom King last year but they
redacted it it's all political
everybody knew it was really me though
you ever see Transformers yeah I wrote
that yeah I date the cheerleaders
hold their ball
yeah I don't uh maybe I don't know yet I
don't recall any of that I don't I
honestly don't feel like we had that
many new kids there was a big school
though it was always big schools
but I don't remember your school was too
big
once you graduate it up uh 1500 years so
they were all like uh they are
it was originally like they're all like
a thousand or Eleven Hundred and then
they said too many kids they split and I
think I graduated like five something
like date yeah a little something like D
um
all right this one's from jaful is it
garbage to GrubHub a burrito to a
wedding because you don't like to spread
come on he said I saw it this weekend
what that's I would ask them to leave
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah if you got
burritos for everybody all right yeah
like an after party like I've I ordered
[ __ ] you know 200 worth of Mexican
food it's coming yeah that's one thing
but you can't
what kind of wedding is that I always
doubt it's like uh that was definitely
outside there was a lot of khakis at
that wedding sure yeah I would I don't
think it would be I just got a burrito I
don't think it was the classiest Affairs
if I had to guess there's probably some
denim not our guy the guy who did it
that guy's a [ __ ] loser oh yeah I
kind of want to punch that guy in the
[ __ ] face okay get a [ __ ] burrito
away then the bride's got to deal with
that
they have like typically weddings I mean
they have like the most generals
if you're ordering a
[ __ ] burrito at a wedding whatever
that wedding has is better than what
you're eating on a regular basis
so act like a [ __ ] adult and go get a
[ __ ] piece of chicken and shut the
[ __ ] up hanger steak or eat something
before you made the choice you got the
car I don't you got the card would you
pick I'll be bringing my own
uh
nothing for me for me please uh but it's
also like
this is coming from a very picky eater
like who like and I'll go like I'll just
go yeah I'm not gonna I'm fine I'm I'm
good I'll just wait I'll leave the
wedding if I'm that hungry I'll leave
the wedding in an hour early and hit a
Chipotle or something if you like a
burrito you like you can eat with
something that they're serving there
yeah of course yeah I'm just saying but
like I get
beam somewhere or whatever and not
liking the what's offered I would never
be like I'm gonna order my own thing I'm
fine you know and you go home and eat
and cry in your bedroom by yourself yeah
100 percent
um
um
uh this one is the same same vein this
one's from Tyler I haven't had one read
yet not much of a question but when I'm
in a pinch
quiche wise he says which is often the
McDonald's and Taco Bell app comes in
clutch sometimes you can catch a free
10-piece nugget with an order of one
dollar or more
so you order the fries for like two
bucks and then you get a free 10 piece
Nuggie so you get lunch or dinner how
you pulling that what do you gotta know
for that I guess it's in that but if you
purchase any T-Bone shaking his head I
don't have any of the apps what do you
mean I doubt you do either it's no the
McDonald's app and the Taco Bell
McDonald's app kept me alive really yeah
did you not hear the question I thought
he meant like ubereats or seamless I
didn't know they had their own platforms
oh yeah with their own special deals in
there really oh yeah who delivers that
you pick it up yourself
I'm out I don't care how cheap how Frida
nuggies are Toby I'm not walking
anywhere and for that reason I'm out
really oh dude the day that I that I
realized that you could get the three or
four nuggets if you ordered four of them
it was like three bucks cheaper than a
10. wait three nuggets yeah three or
four it was four nuggets wait you mean
four orders of nuggets I would get four
orders of four nuggets and it would be
like four dollars cheap I would get
twelve nuggets for like four dollars
cheaper I thought you were ordering
three nuggets three actual nuggets which
I think we were gonna let you go at that
point if that's all you're eating I
thought you were that much of a dirt
ball
hey let me get two nuggets and like a
handful of fries
that's a tough look
what's the bare minimum of nuggets to
eat I
12. no they come in 10 piece don't they
unless you finesse the app
unless you got a guy on the inside
[ __ ] Snowden over here
I'd have been real dirt ball just three
nuggets dude uh yeah you gotta what's
whatever's the the order is I didn't
know about all that
yeah and I think they want to keep you
they want you to order in there so they
[ __ ] throw they throw [ __ ] high
heat at you they want you to order in
the app yeah they get your information
they can send you a [ __ ] push
notifications they got the email they
got all your information seamless and
GrubHub last people you got to talk to
in there less time in the store get your
food and get out fatty yeah sure
um everybody wants the information
yeah information crazy when you control
the mail control information
also by the way this is a bit of a pivot
but did you see that guy in the
McDonald's in New York with the ax what
[Laughter]
man there's this dude
he gets in a fight with like four guys
and is this recent yeah it was like from
like two night last night or something
okay and these four Dudes start punching
this guy in the head and at one point
literally while he's getting punched in
the head by four Dudes he acts like this
isn't bothering me and he puts it he
goes ah I don't know and they're all
just punch him in the head he's like huh
and he goes all right you done yeah and
they're all like yeah all right man like
you're [ __ ] up or something like
you're crazy he just like takes us he's
got like the messenger bag on takes it
off and pulls out a [ __ ] Hatchet axed
a [ __ ] thing and starts going to town
on this McDonald's dude he smashes a
table into pieces with one [ __ ] and
that's whatever he goes oh [ __ ] he
starts smashing like the big glass panes
they have in every it's kick it gets
[ __ ] dicey but Wild
that's what remind me if you're in New
York and you're going to a McDonald's at
that at in the middle of the night never
you're [ __ ] crazy now I'm sure the
barrows are a little different because
it's a little more residential and stuff
like that but if you're going to like do
the one at West 4th Street there would
be fist fights down there every single
the bars let out and then everybody's in
there it's a lot of Street people a lot
of drug addict it's just [ __ ] wacky I
would hit that Mickey D's in the morning
when I was waiting tables over at the
Bareburger
I'd get off at the train there at West
4th Street roll in there
or something no no I'd probably go with
McMuffin a couple McMuffins couple hash
browns um
they had this one girl that was working
at it was literally she was at 10. she
was 10 piece at an absolute ten and I
never had the courage but I was gonna be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing working
here
good kid I guess I don't know some
people were other options I don't I
always find that I don't know how this
is going to sound I always find it crazy
when like super super attractive people
are doing that kind of stuff
I'm like I sleep with somebody do
something sure you gotta have a sugar
mama sugar daddy something it's also
like you never see like a really hot
dude construction worker I'm like he
couldn't get [ __ ] done a little bit
of print work or like a [ __ ] Kohl's
ad and [ __ ] got got some money
together you know what I mean I said I'm
talking about it yeah of course yeah and
cold said
like how
there's just more we were talking about
more opportunity provided to hot people
I want I do it that's what I want to be
around hot people people want to be
around Attractive people yeah so it's
like yeah if I'm sitting if I'm doing it
of course that makes sense that was like
in the town I never really believed that
Ben Affleck worked at the [ __ ] Quarry
I'm like you're too good looking to be
[ __ ]
he was real tight in that too chiseled
cheers we were talking about that what
we were talking about that the other day
in the car I think is that me and you
yeah some like just because somebody's
like super super attractive and has like
really good genes doesn't mean that they
have that you know that they're like
dirt balls like that you know what I
mean
not that they don't realize how
attractive they are they don't use it to
their advantage because they're because
they have good Souls they're good people
does that make sense does that make
sense well yeah okay I guess yeah
they don't look they're so good looking
they've been good looking for so long
that they don't look at if it was you
you'd be using that you know what I mean
all of a sudden you just turned good I
have ugly guy yeah yeah yeah I have ugly
guy perspective
[Laughter]
I get it I get it yeah you don't know
what you got you know yeah yeah you'd
become a who it real quick I'd be
sleeping with every guy everybody guys
um
I don't even know how we got there I
have Angelina Jolie in the Sidecar
I'm gonna you're a lucky girl I'm gonna
see if I can get my hands on that dude
we gave it to my stepdad's nephew I
think what are you gonna go take a bath
from him I mean he's like 30 now he's
still riding him riding it in circles
around the cul-de-sac hello Kevin I knew
you'd be back
yeah very good
um
okay let's see here
um this one's a little wacky this is
from Chad did you ever find sex photos
of your hot aunt and uncle pre-internet
then went to Kinko's to copy them what
that's what's that called that's it
yeah it might have been bestiality I
didn't get a look at these broads dad
was his uncle was a cocker spaniel
um that's tough but I listen he's gonna
have this this feels like we're
violating attorney-client privilege yeah
sure that was from Kevin Ryan
if so photos of them who's taking the
pictures that's that's the other weird
thing sure
there's timers on that kind of stuff I
think on cameras yeah yeah I never got
that was always a thing too you would
see in movies that my family would never
do like sorry I ended up one two then
the dad runs who had to try to there's
not a picture of my dad ever
there ain't one there's one there's one
of like me him and my mom and he don't
look happy to be there he's catching a
eater in his suit I think it was like my
brother I think it was like Danny or
Sarah's communion you always that
somebody in the other family to take
that picture of everybody we never had a
tripod in the movies they always had a
tripod they put on a tripod they think
what never a tripod never no [ __ ]
spatulas yeah nothing my Aunt Patty was
always big on the picks so everybody
used to [ __ ] break her stones for it
uh Patty with the pill Here Comes Pat
meanwhile she was just trying to get
like one picture of everyone like it
wasn't like we were doing a photo she
was like oh let's get a picture of
Christmas and everybody was like get out
I'm not in a you go yeah kids go I'm not
never though yeah never ever ever so I
guess back in the day if you're a young
buck
and you don't there's no internet you
don't have access I don't know I guess
are you doing this guy's story is that
what you're trying to figure this out
yeah I mean I guess what's the guy
Kinkos well hold on I wonder how old
this guy is how long ago we talked
pre-internet pre oh pre-internet yeah so
it's like the 90s yeah late 80s early
90s those guys back then did this did it
say Kinkos he said then you run to
Kinkos
yeah but those guys back then
sex picks working at a photo place
sex pics that was like a that was like a
Christmas bonus I told you I worked at
one hour photo and I waited I that's all
I wanted to see yeah that or a murder
did you ever
[Laughter]
and I almost I got I found pictures and
I was like what the [ __ ] is this man it
really freaked me out
yeah obvious of a like a crime scene but
then as they started developing more as
it was a film set like it was like a
student teacher but like dude I or like
a independent school film or something
hot dude I had nine give me the FBI oh
dude I was about to crack the case dude
I had the name I [ __ ] and I'm like
they'll be back in 15 minutes I was
ready to call them the [ __ ] SWAT team
I had 9-1 dial just ready to [ __ ] get
did you ever find any sexy pics
no uh I I mean
I don't no no was this in the grocery
store yeah
they transferred what would you do that
you got transferred over there no it was
a prima I was behind the counter that
was like uh that was one step up for
being a CSR what's the CSR customer
service representative yes or CSM
customer service manager or something
like that okay
um it's definitely beating the girls
away
one hour photo and a sidecar
ladies
yeah it's a custom job you girls want to
see a picture of my aunt topless
if you wait right over there for 15
minutes I'll slip into my dark room and
uh be right with you no I wasn't done in
a dark room that's old school Janice uh
yeah that's pretty
I get it you're him now I don't get it I
don't get it I'm trying to put it
together while you were aunt and uncle
it could be not his blood ant or maybe
she came in like a little later you know
what I mean all right which is more
gross if the ant is related to you or
the uncle's related I think the amp
because you're lusting after the ant
your uncle's just in there with him he
could be zooming the uncle's got a hug
if you're taking picks back in the day
get the [ __ ] no itsy bitsy teeny weeny
guy doing that not me you get your
Sketchbook out if you want but that's
about it
uh I need some artists some artistic uh
um interpretation license yes yeah yes I
do
yes I do
um hmm
do me a favor do my [ __ ] like one of
those Dolly clocks will you yeah yeah
here's ten keep it clean huh call it
fair will you I don't wanna I don't want
one of them courtroom guys either they
make everybody look an [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here with that
whoever does Garfield get that guy doing
it give me Clifford yeah give me
Clifford
[Music]
um
this one's from Terry the turd know
anyone that can make Kraft mac and
cheese without straining
it took me a minute to get this I had a
roommate in college who could eyeball
the exact amount of water needed till
you never had to strain it that's pretty
good so we just boil but any amount of
water would do that once it just boiled
away sure I figured that out by accident
one time because a strainer when you're
in college or in your early 20s and it's
like a couple guys in an apartment a
strain a clean strainer does not exist
you might have one but there's somebody
you know there's [ __ ] all in it you
typically I'll still do this you go with
the spoon or something or the lid even
the [ __ ] you're losing some mac with
that dude in my OCD it killed the second
I lose one my heart breaks yeah if I
lose a new I get so mad it's just like a
a thing of my if we [ __ ] I think
that's your fatness over your OCD could
be
my carbs but that makes it cheesier
as if it goes in the sink do you take it
out and I've been known to do that oh
never I've been known to do that sure
now not with spaghetti but with macaroni
yeah
or fusilli or rigatoni did you hit the
lotto or did they hit the Daily Number
you guys are you guys are banging with
you silly we had some facility running
around we're big tortellini people too
my mom still is she likes but in a soup
she makes tortellini soup which is like
chicken broth and little tortellinis but
they're all right
pretty bang a little bit of parm cheese
on top where she gets a torts uh she the
pre-made Jones yeah the pre-made John's
either the frozen ones or you know they
have like that fresh pasta at the front
of the thing that's that's all smoke and
mirrors that stuff's awesome and it
ain't that expensive sure because nobody
[ __ ] with it and back in the day it
wasn't at the end it was it was like
with the cheese yeah and the eggs it
still is sometimes yeah nobody goes here
we would that that's we're ingrained to
be like you don't even look at that you
don't I still to this day
Nadine was looking one time and I was a
little bit of chicken broth whoa whoa
hey what's going on here yeah but yeah
it's like 3.99 or whatever yeah it's all
right you totally man
love a tort there you go I love a door
there you go love a dart
um all right let's do one or two more
here then we gotta rip her up this is
from Mike Nish uh is it garbage to go to
the Mall of America on vacation
I that's all I wanted to do as a kid and
Mighty Ducks they were fun they went
[ __ ] rollerblading through it and it
was that Mighty Ducks too I guess it's
in Minnesota
yeah there's a comedy club in there yes
are we there no okay but I was in
Minnesota
oh we were flying we were flying to
Hawaii and then we asked the guy like
hey is there anything we have a couple
hours anything to do like you can go to
the Mall of America
which how big is it there's a roller
coaster in there oh I remember hearing
that as like an eight-year-old you're
like yeah what the [ __ ] yeah can we go
however there's a kid being like I
wonder what that food Court's like
probably like probably four yeah
probably guess how many square feet
700. what's up what
[Music]
what's
a regular mole that's too much that's
too big for me eight million square feet
yeah it's gonna be like square miles
4.8 million square feet yeah wow 96.4
Acres I don't understand what square
feet are anyway I don't get it
I did doesn't make sense to me is it
like how many squares you could fit in
it
or is it if you added up everything
that's how big it is that's all we have
time for today folks
what do you know yeah a square foot is
one foot by one foot
one foot by one foot each side of the
square is one foot
okay so all four sides are one foot so
that's how many of those you could fit
in there so let's just say this room is
10 feet by ten feet that would be a
hundred square feet okay oh because oh
oh that's how you do you could take 10
you could take a hundred one foot so
you'd measure that wall in that wall
yeah all right okay it's not every wall
what around and then add it up
essentially that's what you're doing
though what do you mean oh is it yeah
just multiplying it okay
wait what did you mean like you would
measure from there to there and then
there to there and then there to there
and then there to there and then there
to there and there to there and then you
would add that up all right that was
four feet there that was two feet that
was six feet and eventually that would
get you to whatever it is
now like if you took this room and
opened it up and it was in one straight
line and it was a hundred feet long it
would be a hundred square feet yeah that
would be the perimeter you're talking
about like the perimeter of it because
this also accounts for the inside this
space that we're in here see what I'm
saying
so I add up from from there to there and
there to there and I add that together
and that's the square footage
as long as that wall isn't as long as
that wall is two sides would multiply
them not add them
multiply them
oh so if that's 10 feet and that's five
feet this place would be 50 square feet
okay
look at that a learning program
pretty good
you've like learned it unlearned it and
then relearned it and then then I I go I
then I go I don't know what I'm talking
about
you made me forget it that's how dumb
you are
you [ __ ] you're like the Ooze you
just permeate
he learned it then unlearned it that was
pretty good Tebow McMuffin right there
kids throwing rocks but let's wrap her
up gang gang let me tell you this we
love you we love you do us a favor
subscribe to the YouTube there okay get
on the get on iTunes there leave a nice
review sure the live shows come see a
live show Rhode Island we added a second
show in Boston we had a late show get
those tickets those tickets are live now
get them before they're gone because
they're gonna go I hope yeah let's go
let's sell let's let's sell all those
shows out let's do this let's do it baby
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace